so my name is Ken Stein I me developer
evangelist that neo4j let's get a quick
round of hands if you're a meet-up
regular you've come to our meetups in
the past raise your hand if you're new
to raise your hand so a lot of new
people that's great so we are the San
Francisco graph DB meetup group we are
so neo4j is based in San Mateo but we do
a lot of events here in San Francisco
this is where majority of the ashes
happening so without further ado I will
get started so the talk today is about
uncovering visible relationships using a
graph database so a quick overview so
the agenda i'm going to set some
expectations on what will be going over
today we'll be doing a quick overview of
the 0 for j and then i'm going to show
you how to use neo4j to map the
relationship between content and demand
as well as going over a few customer
quotes and stories
so neo4j is a graph database and it's
used in many different domains
industries just a few examples here we
have HR recruiting healthcare science
telcos manufacturing logistics energy
finance and of course most important
life web and social so what is neo4j
typically used for so social networks
huge one right you have people you have
relationships between people Twitter for
example you can follow somebody on
facebook you can be friends with someone
so these are all explicit relationships
that neo4j can graph and map out and
allow you to query it in a way that
gives you a lot of power over using a
relational database so network impact
analysis so let's assume that you have a
set of servers or applications mapping
the dependencies between them to
understand impacts somewhere or a single
point of failure so a popular one is
route finding show me the route between
point A and point B a very simple
example here we have the London tube but
Google Maps is another good example
recommendations so a user who view next
also viewed life it's a classic example
if you use amazon com you'll see a
little this little widget sometimes at
the bottom of page you're viewing a
product which shows you some other
things you may be interested for example
Doctor Who so logistics and parcel
routing so you want to deliver a car
soul to destination how does it get
there has to go through a few data
centers so do forte is great for that as
well access control so you're not
instead of applications web services and
you want to impose a layer security on
top of them for certain users so you
have users that are mapped to services
which they can access and there's
certain chains of dependencies and
access control inherited permissions and
so graph is a good natural medium to be
able to model that so one of my
favorites fraud analysis so analyzing
first party bank fraud from looking at
patterns within the graph actual visual
patterns an example of this is you have
a set of synthetic identities that are
created from a few real identities and
so certain pieces of information are
shared among a ring in first party bank
fraud and so a graph can be used to
understand that pattern and to analyze
the risk to see to notify certain
responsible parties that they should
investigate so these are just a few
examples of what you can use neo4j to do
so let's get into the next part of
thought which is graphing content demand
so I'm going to go ahead and set some
expectations again so I'm going to
describe the problem in
jizz in doing this I'm going to answer a
few questions so what are invisible
relationships which is the title of this
talk so what the heck are those things
so how do you infer relationships using
a graph data model how do you graph the
demand for social content which is a big
one and how do you distribute valuable
content where it is most demanded
essentially creating an economy for
content so let me describe some problems
and challenges they might want to do so
there is all this digital content out
there and people don't know that it
exists so you might find yourself
sometimes on the internet maybe music
service you said I have a set of
interests and you're being design of
content recommending content well
sometimes it you're just you can find
yourself going through all of these
posts and not finding really something
that you like so there is content out
there for you like content that you will
find interesting it's just that it's
hard to find there's just so much data
out there and it's getting so complex so
every day there's there's people write
blog posts every day on interesting
things and so it's there's definitely
that piece of content out there for you
it's just really tough to find because
there's not a lot of good ways to be
able to map demand content so that's
what i want to show you how to do using
your Portugal so some development
challenges if you're using a relational
database recommendation engines are hard
to develop and time-consuming so the
challenge here is that data modeling on
relational databases isn't fun and that
comes from personal experience going
from having to design that our
enterprise resource diagrams and table
schemas is a pain in the butt and so
it's not a lot of fun but when I went to
start using the O forge a new graphic
model
just like a hippie for me I was like wow
this is a lot of fun and it was even
more fun to realize that ok now just
query these chains to be able to do
things they're really really difficult
using relational database so in essence
it's boring it's hard to remember and
it's also very hard to articulate to
collies relationship tables so the
solution neo4j doesn't just give you an
awesome Oh to the source graph database
it also provides you with a new way of
thinking which is really important so
there's not just the product the
technology that's not just the
innovation the innovation here is that
you have a whole new way of thinking
about data and connected data and how
did is related to other pieces of data
and that is something that Starling
needed today in a way that's I guess
more interesting for people to use and
so our community you'll find lots of
tweets on Twitter saying how much people
enjoy using our database to do data
modeler and that happens every day and I
love seeing it and I had that moment too
I remember when I first started using
you for Jay assault of a problem and I
was just like wow this this is the
future I tweeted it and we'll retweet it
so yes so it's easy it's fun and you
don't need to be a 10 x developer to be
able to build freaking awesome ass so
here's a example of relational schema
it's pretty ugly you can't really look
at this and understand the relationships
between these tables so make sure you
have some properties just formulation
primary key but it's kind of tough to
see exactly from just one image what is
really into life so we use a property
grabbed a law which allows you to
explicitly set these relationships they
represent it in a way that's really easy
to understand and articulate so here for
example it's like a movie domain so we
have Tom Hanks and Hugo Weaving Tom
Hanks acted in Cloud Atlas with hugo
weaving and then q awaiting also after
the matrix which was directed by lot
opacity so that's really easy to
articulate it's very natural and so date
of the data modeling process is very
natural as well so that's why it's a lot
of fun so what are what are these things
called invisible relationships so here's
just a little example graph we have
behaviors we have content yet in trivia
people we have brands now what are these
things having to do with each other and
and so that's really where the invisible
relationships come in you have a set of
explicit relationships that maps these
pieces of content together but there's
an opportunity to make inferences to be
able to generate recommendations which
you would have been able to do using a
relational database or you could just it
would be very difficult so let's go over
some examples of these explicit
relationships so for example you have
people who follow people you have people
who share content and you have people
who like content and you have people who
have interests this is key to this
example is that you have these people
who have explicitly stated an intra
XYZ now a lot of times people really
don't know a piece of content that they
really want it may be completely
unrelated to their interest but it may
still be interesting to them based off
of their collective experience so what
are some examples of invisible
relationships in a social network so the
thing is classic examples you have a
friend of a friend so you have a network
of people and you can have a friend in
common with somebody else so if I were
friend relationships a visible
relationship which is easy to do in
neo4j you have people who aren't
demanding content now how do you how do
you predict that is is what I'm going to
be answering today an actual example
using cypresses our query language and
also you have content which supplies
interests and i'll be going over so how
do you infer relationships using a graph
data model so the goal is to best
understand how to deliver highly
valuable content to a social network you
have all this content out there which
may or may not be valuable to the people
within that network so it's not one size
fits all approach it say how do i
distribute out this piece of content to
where it's going to be most demanded and
value so that's the problem that that
I'm going to show you today and the
problem that is really still existing
out there in the web application space
mobile space and social networks in
general so the idea here is that you
want two min connections where value can
be quantified in quantized and measure
and by using a graph database that's
that's quite simple because you have
these relationships which are explicit
and have types between pieces of content
so here it's setting on the example
let's assume that we have users who who
can share content so let's just say this
is Twitter it's easy so and Twitter you
have users who share content via
retweets right or just posting it and
they get retweeted so sharing it with
other users is an active I think that
people who follow me who have similar
interests will find this interesting
right that's the idea here so you have
these users who share content and they
also have a set of interests pretty soon
now the invisible relationships is seen
here so here you can see that a Content
supplies and interests both on top and
bottom and we can infer that because we
know that a user who shared a piece of
content has a set of interest even
though the content may not be related to
the interest it's still interesting
based off of the users experience and
that will make more sense a sudden so
the big question that is how do you
graph the demand for social content so
going back to the example now here's a
example graph this isn't a neo4j 210
browser and so I'm going to set the
stuff best I can if you can't read it
all the way the back I apologize so here
we have a set of people who are blue so
we have an one we have Chris we have
makayla we have lowers we have myself we
have Amanda and we have basin which are
all my colleagues and they have a set of
interests so we can see that animals
interested in big data he's also
interested in venture capital it was
sequel in startups so we also see that
I'm interested in native mining I'm
interested in star
and interested in machine learning and
technology we see that Amanda share some
of those injuries but she's also an
active video game player which she
doesn't share with anybody else in this
graph that's where this dangling no
doubt here is and so fix it I'll just go
over everybody cuz it will make sense we
go to the demo so Nick's it is
interested in predictive analytics is
interested in databases interested in no
sequel and interested in big data and
these yellow bubbles are content so the
content has a title so let's just say
it's an article and I've pre-populated
just example the titles are fairly long
they don't really fit in the graph so
that's why I have an interest on them
and they share these pieces of content
so I'm going to jump to my down real
quick
I'm just going to speak loud because I
can't type and play with you afford a at
the same time all right so here's the
neo4j browser no that's not it one
second
ok
soon
maybe we'll see that ok pack the room
thumbs up great ok this is a neo4j to
point out browser if you're not familiar
with it I will do a quick little intro
gear so it's a web-based it's
essentially a web-based shell so you're
interacting with a database he is cypher
queries which is our declarative query
language and that's that's done here
through our little console you have
history so after you put in a few
queries and executed them you can go up
and down look at your history it's very
useful you can favorite queries using
the star their top right and on the left
you have some informative panels so you
can see kind of introspect and see
what's in the database you have a set of
new labels relationship type some
property keys and then in the favorites
tab you can actually go and look and see
what queries you've previously saved and
also you can introspect the database
even more I'd like to use this example
it's what is related and mountain and so
that query tells us that we have these
let's zoom in a little bit more we see
that users can be interested in
interests we can see that users can
share pieces of content and that content
supplies interests so now I'm going to
just clear the database setup the demo
going to my favorites
and so then i'm going to set up the
example here which is our graph that i
showed you an image of earlier okay so
if i scroll down this is the simple
setup script so you can see that I've
mapped the connections between people
using cipher and ciphers a very clever
query language which is akin to ascii
art you have nodes which are in
parentheses you have relationships that
are in square brackets and you have
arrows which describe the direction of
the relationship and I have my pieces of
content and I'm just going to go over
those real quick so it makes sense so we
have content one and I picked these kind
of not at random but I went on get
prismatic which is kind of a neat app
and they have tax related to piece of
content I kind of just inherited that
and so here are our first piece of
content is analyst boxes only realistic
option is to sell the company and then
we have content number two is
decision-making trees and machine
learning resources for our number three
we have no sequel job trends
february2014 for a massive market
opportunity awaits and analyzing the
Internet of Things five is meet factual
the self fashion force multiplier for
big data and number six creepy website
shows how much Facebook knows value and
so these pieces of content all have
certain they're now actually mapped to
interest and that's what we're going to
be doing we're going to infer the
relationships based off of what people
are interested and what they share so
each of these people have shared a piece
of content which I've set up here and
now we want to create the relationships
that don't it don't exist and so let me
go ahead and run this
bless you
okay so that sets it up let's look at
the graph I'm going to run a simple
cipher query here which returns us
everything in the graph and gives us a
nice pretty d3.js visualization here
which is exactly that image I showed you
the slides it's a lot of fun to play
with data if you haven't done it it's
quite a rush and so yeah so we have
interest we have content we have users
now that's where our graph looks like so
now let's go to the second step so let's
uncover the invisible relationships
between content and interests so let's
pull up that site for queer you go over
it so i'm just going to explain what the
cypher query does so based off of the
graph we've already created here top at
the point of this is some cover those
invisible relationships between content
and interests by creating a supplies
relationship so here online to you have
content which is shared by a user and
you want to match that pattern in the
database and then you have users who are
interested in interests which again is
explicit now we're saying okay now with
these things and the aggregate of
interest says the weight build a
relationship between all of the content
and the interests that the people have
who have shared pieces of content and to
aggregate those into a weight on the
relationship which qualifies it because
we want to understand to how much a
piece of content potentially is related
to an interest in our network so if i
run that it goes and it creates all of
these relationships so here these are
all new relationships i just created
them and we have here and orange or red
is the interest and then we have yellow
piece of content and now you can see 136
has a whole bunch of tags right into it
and each one of these relationship have
a weight based off of the amount of
times that people the network had shared
it with a certain set of relationships
so we aggregated that and put it into
the relationship so from there the next
step except question oh yes can you do
that same query we have creating the
relationships the same query without
explicitly creating the relationships no
because they don't exist right so you
can use a return back pieces of content
I think it might be useful for
illustration here of what I'm doing so
now I'm running the first part of that
query without creating anything and
let's just return back content types of
property interest duck piece is title
and then let's return back the way we
act
so here you see let me zoom out a bit
all those pieces of content that I went
over earlier and you see that we they're
related to these interests which people
have and that there's a weight
associated with it and where that weight
comes from if we remove that with line
we can look at this completely
denormalized but we have piece of
content we have users with names and
then we have the user set of interests
just going to title so that query
returns fat to see a lot of redundancy
here insis is where I'm aggregating and
getting that some and putting on the
relationship so if we order by the
interest title let's give out an alias
sir s
so here we have these interests which
are related to these articles and so
that's where the counts coming from just
normalizing it into a graph structure so
it makes sense so that's that's fairly
important for doing the recommendations
later alright so now we've done that we
can go and we can generate
recommendations so I'm going to pull
that up actually let's go ahead and look
at the whole graph now just evolved
since we have added in supplies
relationships so it's much more
connected
and now let's go ahead and do some
recommendations so provide a
recommendation based on demand so let's
just iterate through the people that we
know so here we have fixit who has a set
of interests and those interests are
supplied by pieces of content which he
has not shared because we don't want to
do content he's already shared and so
that's what this little where clause
does where it says we're not use your
shared content then to return back the
content title and then to some the
weights of the relationships together
and then to order by that descending so
we see that we have a little
recommendation here that vixen probably
would be interested based off of his
interest in his behavior on the network
on no sequel job trends in february2014
so if we go back and we match fix its
interests
fix it
interested
and we return
so we can see that fix it like Zen
resident no sequel databases big data
predictive analytics pretty in line with
that piece of contents a small D is set
but it is what vixen would based off
with his history of what he's both
shares and what he's interested in would
want to read and that gets better with
more data so as you add more data you're
going to get better recommendations so
let's try Lars who is our vp of upset
neo and see let's see what Lars is
interested in
so Lars is interested in startups he's
interested in predictive analytics he's
interested in no sequel and interested
in venture capital so based off of these
four interests we can recommend to Lars
what he would be most likely to want to
read and athlete he probably would want
to read about a massive market
opportunity awaits and analyzing the
Internet of Things which is kind of
actually cool because I didn't kind of
like backwards pick these examples
actually just kind of randomly pick them
out and so it actually worked pretty
well based off of what I kind of knew
about people and so I was pretty happy
with it so here again you have the
weight which is a some of the
relationships weights and then they're
ordered and so in the UI you would show
that you might want to show the top
result and then after they've read that
one the next one yeah okay yes all right
so let's go through let's see what emals
interested in
ample saw our CEO and fearless leader by
the way and he's interest in startups
he's interested in big data is
interested in venture capital as well as
no sequel among many other things what
should my read no sequel job trends
february2014 sounds about right cool all
right so so that's the demo I'm going to
jump back to some slides I'm actually
going to open it up for questions now I
have some more stuff that I'm going to
talk about but let's break it up a
little bit so I'll open up the floor for
questions on this example so if you have
any questions feel free to ask name and
then also I need to repeat your question
for the perry yeah how does it does kill
you how does neo4j scale yeah for this
type of weakness so it scales well for
these types of queries you're going to
want it's going to be based off your use
case this use case you're going to have
a lot of concerns that you're going to
want to manage if you were to import
data on a regular basis but because this
model that I've developed here is really
just doing mutating operations using
cipher it's actually quite performant
because you're not having to analyze
data too much you're just kind of
creating relationships between things
and then as its scale since these
relationships have already been created
that it's a large part of the graph
you're only updating parts of the graph
that don't have those in this
relationships yet so it does scale up
yes
dimension
how recent was to share our recent
content and using the weight room so
adding in a time to mention right yeah
so I recently did talk building a
graph-based analytics platform which
uses models time appropriately and yes
it would be quite easy to put that in
here you after all your calendar you
would have a unique day with a timestamp
and that day can be related to a month a
year even half weeks that are connected
two days and from there you can add
different scales aggregate to understand
what behavior looks like at those scales
and then you can integrate that into
this because then have a single day note
or a single aggregate node which should
be a week and you would just map that to
a piece of the content based off of what
behavioral pattern you come up with that
make sense
is there a way to building a strength of
essentially defined the way
yeah so for which edge let's see
let's say scale one to five
so ratings that the user has included
yeah so you can then use that as a
multiplier you probably want to use some
mathematical function that makes sense
for this domain and recommendations so
it may be some machine learning and it's
been done we have graph chests which are
we have these this project which our
developer evangelist do which shows you
active examples on a website using our
database and one of the examples is
recommending movies using kay Ayers
neighbor and cosine similarity and
that's kind of a similar thing to what
we're talking about the user rates piece
of content and then it does some
clustering algorithm to figure out how
to modify the edges based off of the
recommendation ok you can store that
right into the relationship just the
graph database our graph database allows
you to store key values in any dentist
relationships endnotes any other
questions that so
just gave
that's another cycle that
did so i'm just gonna repeat the
question for the cameras so you asked
that if this example was done outside of
its its using one hundred percent cipher
okay so that i create a sample dataset
using cipher and then from there i did
the analysis using cipher back yes right
so in a property graph data model you
can give key values to any entity so
relationships and those and those data
types can be an integer being a float it
can be any of the job of integrating
days legs food be your key too low or
you sorry it would be here akiko
properties hierarchical property so in a
graph database to model higher case you
would just use notes and relationships
and from there you would use cipher to
sniff out those higher fees based off of
whatever your use case was started
yeah you probably wouldn't want to put I
guess I it would be missing out on the
opportunity to use a graph database to
model these types of things if you put
it into a property but you can't create
maps which have like Jase on map
property any other questions yes so we
support a bunch of language bindings
actually in some of the last slide so
I'll go over that all right so let's
continue on
switchbacks
ok
so we went over all that okay and then
again i pointed out right content may
have nothing to do with interest that it
supplies that's okay because people
don't know what they want sometimes okay
so i went over the large example a lot
fit the power of graph databases so i'm
going to conclude next couple slides by
kind of going going over some of the
more of the general guidelines and what
graph databases are really doing within
the market right now and how how we're
really finding customers that are first
of all have huge big problems and they
need a graph database have needed a
graph database for a long time and so
they've turned to us so graph databases
provide a means to draw valuable
inferences at very large scales which is
really important and hard to do in
relational database so in a relational
database you're doing joints and to be
able to traverse through data you have
to do dynamic joins which is real pain
button on so graph databases give you a
declarative query language to be able to
traverse this data and that's just built
in so graph databases are great tool to
deliver richer experiences through
personalized online interactions and
content discovery and that's based off
of being able to analyze certain
patterns of behavior over time and then
to connect those aggregates to other
nodes to be able to generate these
recommendations based off of traversals
and so then this relationships on a
social network are the ones that haven't
been made yet so they're out there it's
just figuring out where they are and
then creating them and then from there
it offers a whole new layer of
opportunity because from there you are
able to create another layer of hidden
relationships and doing this over and
over again allows you to draw tremendous
inferences which are valuable so there
is also a huge opportunity to connect
people with content that they demand and
so that is kind of I think what is key
to medium so i thought i'd add that in
there is that that's exactly they're
trying to solve so kudos to them it
could have spent for looking to us to
help them do that so let's go over some
few customer quotes and i'll wrap it up
so James this is one of our customers
they are based in the UK they're an
online gambling company and so here's a
quote from Toby or oak O'Rourke
Technical Architect a game system using
neo4j allowed us to focus on the
important parts of the project getting
the domain model right extracting novel
insights from the data and delivering
business value quickly so glassdoor
who's familiar with glass door calm rage
mia so pretty popular website lots of
data so what they do is they're
essentially they provide insight
information information economy that
people can use to do research on
competitive career salaries and market
so you have these people who join the
website and they discreetly and
anonymously offer up some information
and they're given some information in
return and so they use they use our
database to model these connections and
so the quote here from glassdoor which
is just I guess a quote from the company
I don't have a name but the neo4j graph
database proved the perfect fit for
integrating Facebook into the glass door
community as a result we were able to
provide a better experience
for our members and provide them with
real job recommendations so they wanted
to do recommendations to people based
off of a certain set of features and
most recently which is really exciting
is crunchbase upgraded their services to
2 point 0 which is powered by neo4j and
so I just took a quote right off their
blog post about their business graph
where they mentioned us and so the quote
is that from Matt coffee who's the
president of crunchbase creating the
business graph requires a technology
platform that can expand and evolve with
an ever-changing dataset crunchbase 2
point 0 is built on a graph database
design for applications where you can't
neatly predict what data you might add
down the road or what queries you might
throw at the data it's a really powerful
book so that that is all I have for you
today I want to thank you for for coming
and listening to my talk I'll be around
for questions afterwards also I will
open up the floor again for questions
and maybe some of the other neo4j
employees that are here want to answer
some questions as well but I should make
one final announcement smart people come
work with me so we're looking for
awesome data sciences to join the
NeoGraft so if you are data scientists
that are interested in working with us
and solving really big problems talk to
you myself or any other neo employees
here animal and if your nail employee
raised ranch now you know they're great
thank you guys get in touch with me if
you have questions and I will open it up
for you
poop and we'll have to get some ok
questions any other questions do we get
it all yes
No
so let's so it goes back to the idea
that in our business problem we're
trying to solve we have the stead of
explicit we have explicit knowledge week
we know we know that people can follow
people right that's that's a business we
will rip the application and so from
there we we know bad relationship exists
and we can add that relationship to the
graph now the implicit relationships are
ok now I have all of these explicit
relationships how do i cleverly find a
way to draw inferences to deliver value
and so that's that's the idea behind so
to answer your question you need
relationships to be able to add
relationships any other questions
yes so I can't off the top of my head
actually I'm Heather not good at neo4j
calm you can find all of well a lot of
our use cases we have a new website
which really does a great job telling
you all about our customers and their
stories and their examples you can also
go to gist neo4j work to find community
contributed example use cases using our
graphs just project which again is a
little mini website application that
uses our database to prove certain
things he's inside there is a number of
customers daily net bother denying in
fact is even a portion vfj called the
other day bright by over there by every
day but that's some specialized stuff in
that domain so yeah look the guys that I
really like make sense like this
connector
do you have any mental to cover
disconnect ambala to the question which
is is covering some disconnected sub
graphs or cluster nodes during the way
they'll put it that either are ways to
do it there's a lot of different ways to
do it and it's dependent on viewer
scenario your new space so it is really
no general rule to do that but using yes
you can do clustering and you can use
cipher to do clustering but you'll
probably want to do post processing
which is to export it to some format to
do some type of graph analytics you can
use SI use gevey to do some cool stuff
with visualization as well as some graph
analytics and clustering node coloring
so any other questions
yes curious you there was a question
here about whether you could actually do
some of these kinds of queries without
actually creating these extra nodes and
links and what I'm wondering about is if
you have some analysis you want to do
you want to get a result out of it and
then you kind of want to throw a lot of
this stuff away you don't want to keep
it around in your database I assume
there's some way to tag your nose the
links and then and then clean them out
afterwards what that seems kind of
lonely so it actually would be quite
easy to solve losing the boat so the
question was that can you so after
you've created these inferences
relationships these you've actually made
implicit relationships explicit maybe
you want to maintain your graph so you
don't have all of these relationships
lying out there that you don't need
anymore and so the answer is yes you can
tag those relationships in many
different ways you can tag notes to
those relationships based off of another
node and you can also put properties on
those relationships which you can
specify delete by a certain date or
based off the second criteria go and
delete these relationships and you can
select on
so yes how does neo4j handle
concurrent reads and writes and so neo4j
handles it very well because that's what
it does so you have concurrent reason
right it does yes absolutely last year
though we were going to put out a new
product from how they made it normally
does right now really really fast for
Ryan really fast again super sense yes
so it does the data out of it yes so
it's a our art database is fully acid so
that is something that you'll probably
would be interested in doing
transactions and rolling back
transactions and we have a rest api that
integrates so primary mode for most
people these days using cipher is
through our REST API and we actually
have a transactional endpoint which
allows you to post transactions to an
end point to commit them or two to roll
them back it's just some other
information any other questions yes
so there's there's not any built-in
security protocols other than basic off
which your it's your responsibility to
put it behind a firewall in to map it in
such a way that doesn't expose them to
any breast and huh graph sir yeah it's
kind of a chicken and egg problem yeah
yeah so but to access control ism is a
use case for grass but I think you're
talking about more of like in sequel you
have assess servers that you have logins
and credentials when it has built-in
access management so we don't have fat
yet any other questions cool thank you
guys I really appreciate it and then if
you have any other questions for the
gang or you're really smart if you want
to work with us please come up and talk
to me oh right yes very important um
yeah so if you go to neo4j or corsage
drivers you can find all the drivers
that we support we support loads of
drivers they're written by open source
community mostly and so just go to the
website and if you actually have a
question as to whether or not we support
your driver the answer is probably yes
and there's open source projects which
have to find side drivers to be able to
communicate with our davis so with that
I will wrap it up thank you everyone